Digital Extremes a complete video game  company London they have a demo warframe  and there's this evil crew called the  corpus and I challenge the corpus to  finally do some good in the galaxy um  and take the ice bucket challenge  cut the Iliad big gay al s dr. Joe point  yeah yeah it'd be a Jo se sintió patek  yeah clear day at the a on Ethiopia  Julia some days you can poet huh  you're back tidbi Jamaica yes what the  kid jumper you're guilty jack Alan  people tapping it up okay Alice should  capture capture at odd day attache Lou  Gehrig's Pio to shampoo capacities into  a key acaba Papa did you cook not bad  baby duck at key boy is a catchy yogurt  a Japan Takuto check  goodbye ugh  you  [Music]